how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we recently got some new information
about Avengers in-game with the latest
issue of total film magazine we didn't
get any new pictures or any new looks at
the Avengers but we did get some new
interviews with the Russo brothers who
direct the film and the writers
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
and in this interview they basically
tell us that we have no idea what
Avengers endgame is really going to be
about I'll break down what they all said
in this video but first if you're new to
my channel be sure to subscribe
I do monthly giveaways right now I'm
giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet and a art painting of fan oohs
from globe by Bo I'll talk more about it
at the end of the video but all you have
to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so a lot
of people have heard that the marketing
campaign for Avengers endgame is
supposed to be way different than
anything that we've seen in the past for
Marvel but many people are wondering
what exactly is so different about what
they've been doing so far and this is a
question that the magazine asked as well
in which jurors our plight that the
marketing is unique and he said we're
being very selective with the material
that's going into the trailers there are
a lot of people out there that want to
be surprised and we want there to be
room for surprises we just want to make
sure that they can't predict anything
that might happen anything that gives
anyone context or you know spoils the
movie in any way we're going to keep it
under a lock so Joe Russo basically just
came out and said that the trailers give
no context about the movie whatsoever
and that he wants us to be completely
surprised when we see the movie so he's
not giving anything away in the trailers
they then go on to ask them how do they
keep all of these spoilers from leaking
and they go on to talk about how they
did it with infinity war executive
producer Trent Tran said it was
especially difficult towards the end too
because the big spoiler at the end of
infinity where it was that half of our
favorite characters died so those pages
didn't actually exist at all
we didn't publish those or give those
out so not even the cast had those we
had to verbally tell the folks that they
were dying in person in-game was
especially hard in that sense because we
felt that pretty much the entire movie
was a spoiler so the Russo brothers
don't want any spoilers about the movie
getting out in the trailers but the
whole entire movie is basically one big
spoil
and the Russo brothers say that we get
no context from the trailers so this
explains why the marketing is so
different
most of these scenes in the trailers
probably won't be in the movie or
they're going to be completely different
than what we expect them to be the Russo
brothers have already said that they use
footage for the trailers that don't end
up being in the movies and that they
want the trailers to tell a specific
story but not give away any part about
the movie and again this is to avoid any
possible spoilers about the movie
because they say that we really don't
know anything about the movie when
comparing infinity war to end game
screenwriter Christopher Markus goes on
to say without being able to reveal
anything about endgame they're very
different movies structurally and
tonally and that was always the
intention from the moment Kevin kind of
laid out the layers of what these would
be that they would be two completely
different movies so if you're expecting
Avengers and game to be like Avengers
infinity war don't it is clear from what
the directors the writers and the
producers are telling us that we really
don't know what this movie is about and
we won't before it comes into theaters
because they're intentionally trying not
to give us any context about the movie
so with all the promotionals and the
trailers that they're releasing they're
giving us just enough to get excited
about the movie but not enough to know
what's actually happening so don't
expect to know the true story of what is
happening in Avengers endgame just based
off of the trailers but let me know what
you think about this do you think that
any parts of the trailers are actually
what they seem or do you think that all
of the trailers are just massive
misdirection and that we're going to be
completely mind blown when we go see
Avengers endgame let me know what you
think in the comments down below and
again right now I'm giving away a
life-sized Infinity Gauntlet and a
Thanos painting by glow by beau you can
check out the painting and the rest of
his artwork at globe by beau calm I'll
put it down in the description and of
course be sure to subscribe if you want
to stay up to date on everything
relating to Avengers endgame and all
things Marvel as always thank you all so
much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]